most important things this of course you
have to dress you have to dress as a
bonus a gym here you're in your boxer
shorts because I'm a boxer it's a fight
it's a it's a fashion magazine right
this is what you normally wear look I
spent a couple afternoons with Bruno
Mars and he was in this underwear
I mean I requested that he put just be
in his underwear and he never did it
because he's like a tight
he was like watching a football game now
as I put on the guard some tight
underwear okay and he was like no and
then he called the cops it was long
story you teachable you arrest it
yeah I mean how much did you have to pay
a thousand eighteen thousand dollars oh
gosh I walked by jon Hamm's house sure I
loved on him like 12 times and he was
like hey what's going on I said I told
him I got the hand you know I like bacon
maybe we should go swimming together oh
gosh he didn't say that did you yeah oh
my and he there is he he was like um why
are you in my driveway and I'm just
walking by mm-hmm because I have like
you know gates down there that you've
climbed over and I was like I don't even
noticed those